or we're joined by Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning good morning so let's start with
this tax reform announcement here it
seemed to catch members of president
Trump's own administration as well as
Treasury officials by surprise what's
happening here well this is going to be
different than health care because Trump
is going to have his own plan and he's
gonna roll it out as earlier this week
Wednesday we're hearing sometimes that
those can slip this is a big deal I
think it's going to be very hard to get
tax reform cutting taxes is one thing
but when you revamp the entire tax code
there are winners and losers lobbying
fights is going to be very difficult
it's not going to be easier than health
care the tax code which hasn't been
rewritten since 1986 yes is there a plan
actually like in the works because I
mean as Alex mentioned it seemed like
the administration was caught completely
off guard when he said this yeah well
Paul Ryan has his plan but at the same
time there's this controversial tax on
imports that doesn't have the vote
certainly in the Senate maybe not in the
house the administration has given mixed
reviews on that and that's just one
element of what of how controversial
this will be the president has said it's
going to be the what may be one of the
most massive tax cuts ever for
individuals and businesses yeah to that
to this sort of aggressive posture we're
seeing legislatively from this White
House health care the White House
insists it's not done with the plan yet
it's not done with trying how likely is
something actually to get through the
house at this point I don't think any
time soon they were talking about a vote
this week I mean that's not going to
happen I mean members have to know
what's in the bill and that's the
problem with the first time the first
bill they rushed it through and members
didn't know and it wasn't popular they
hadn't really no message for that health
care bill so they're trying to get the
Conservatives on board but Alex as you
know if you lose if you if you move the
bill the right you're going to lose the
moderates and these moderates are very
angry that the freedom clock is a
conservative freedom caucus is being
wooed and they feel like they're being
ignored they don't want to take benefits
from their constituents so this is going
to be very difficult just to get through
the house and then to go to the Senate
yeah it could take months yeah and then
meantime these congressmen are hearing a
lot of push back in town halls all over
the country that's right that's right
and and that's why these moderates
usually in the house you can kind of
roll them you can convince them to get
to yes but if they think that this is
the end of their
career well then they're gonna have a
spine let's talk about the political
optics here the president is insisting
the first 100 days doesn't matter yeah
but this action would seem to suggest
that they think it very much does matter
yeah they want to show progress at least
if they got it through the house it
would be a big victory for them I don't
think they can ever stop saying well
we're done with with health care we're
done with repealing Obamacare so they've
got to keep trying but getting the votes
is going to be very difficult and it
could be really handicapped to them in a
midterm election so if you look at the
president's contract with america which
is his 100-day plan where does he stand
well he got a big win with neil Gorsuch
getting him on the supreme court and
he's taken eradicated some Obama era
regulations other than that
legislatively you know they've been 0
for I mean they have not gotten tax
reform knocked on health care they have
they don't have really they're nowhere
on the wall which right big deals so
right now now Paul Ryan and Mitch
McConnell say don't judge us on a
hundred days judge us on 200 days
because they they knew that this was
going to be such a heavy lift but health
care should have been done by well not
been done and they control Congress ya
know they control everything that's
exactly it makes that 044 score that you
point out particularly searing for them
I think yeah and that that's the problem
is that Democrats also the tone has been
set in this first hundred days Democrats
have no incentive to work with this
administration nor really have they been
encouraged to no not yet all right Bob
Cusack thanks